[Aplausos]
a veces para ser imposible
nos guardemos
estamos hablando
y lo que yo
y nunca se le va a dar
pero
tomar en cuenta lo que aprender en este
cuadro
esto es lo que más experiencia tanto
como estudiante como aprendizaje
pero
y
[Música]
bueno
nuevos cursos dice sabes
lo mejor que puedes hacer
y hoy
y esté aquí la parte de la grama
y la verdad
pero
en el país
y el vocabulario
parece sencillo ya veces le digo que
como adultos empezamos
pero recuerda de recordar la tela
bueno ahora decimos el problema
y
y ahora sí
llegó no se notase estrés
muchísimo
y
y nos dicen no puede utilizar
[Música]
incorrecto pensar
y vamos
por eso lo que tenemos
d
no olvidemos
y además nos puede servir mucho
[Música]
esto es amor
como éste no contaba una frase
el maestro de álava
es
nos encontramos con un punto esencial
en la traducción del problema
la enseñanza es la traducción debemos
evitar a toda costa la traducción porque
yo no puedo caer ayudar del amor común
sí
no
y quiere regresar está diciendo algo la
persona expresa
cuando yo
no lo que tenemos que hacer aquí como
podemos que brindar traducir al abrazar
aprendiendo
bueno
y recordar las reglas y el vocabulario
y obviamente no
así que
y como una práctica
de manera natural
le digo si me ayuda
cómo
parecidas al español pero no es lo mismo
de hecho entonces le digo
continuamos porque las limitaciones son
muchísimas y me imagino que también hay
personas que dicen ya tengo mucho
conocimiento real de ser yo entiendo
absolutamente todo lo que me dicen no
tengo ningún problema
como grupo
encontramos la pronunciación a veces nos
da miedo hablar porque sí
este
y cuál es el problema bueno para esto
haciendo
[Música]
incluso puedes ver que la connotación
es
es divertido entonces por qué
así que tenemos que comprender eso
haciendo mi pronunciación de nada la
pronunciación
para mejorar la pronunciación
no debo
bien
y
artistas muy codiciados de dos tiempos
que todo el mundo son mexicanos
[Música]
totalmente
ah
tengo me conoces
porque lo que queremos
no no
y es parte
pero no es el problema
a veces mucho
por lo menos tiene
llega
más dinero por un pelo largo
pero lo que sea
y ser conscientes de que todos los días
utilizamos
la empresa
de dar ese paso
y a veces lo que hacemos
abierto alrededor de la ciudad
camisetas en las bolas que no nos damos
cuenta ni siquiera
entonces
y
el traductor en el celular es muy fácil
de acceder a este tema
es
consigo
el acelerador
y el blogs
no lo sé
[Música]
tenemos muchísima la palabra
juntos
[Música]
lo que sabemos
va a ser muchísimo mejor bueno el
siguiente punto y yo estoy en contra
agencias
y siempre
el niño o el adulto no sé qué vamos a
decir el niño porque tiene
con más bocas
[Música]
lo vemos en la pronunciación llegamos y
de los sonidos
mejor que antes
y aparte
sin embargo a través del tiempo los
lingüistas de edad
los dos
la verdad
una realidad
sí
lo que pasa si nos volvemos
en esta posición
presente
y el niño de mañana
de esa manera el acercamiento
[Música]
pero no
también el vocabulario de próximas
cuentas
d
y yo
para saberlo
y el niño no va a saber absolutamente
todo
entonces
sí no
y aplicar a las necesidades
así
sí
muchas pero muchas
así que como cuenta pues aparte de la
constancia
a
desarrollo
el interés es no saber nada
televisión
[Música]
se va aprendiendo muchísimo más
a poder hacer
y bueno no te olvides
para saber qué alcance
de manera
[Música]
[Aplausos]